well I hope you had a great weekend a
wonderful Mother's Day as well I can
tell you that well I think my wife had a
great Mother's Day she she really loved
especially the vacuum cleaner that I got
her as a gift and I knew that she loved
it because as soon as she unwrapped it
the first words out of her mouth or I
can't believe you would do this and I
said I know it's it's unbelievable it is
unbelievably generous of me but that's
just the kind of guy I am
and I even included I had a car of
course and in the card there was this
little what I called a kind of a
treasure map you know a little bit silly
but it's a treasure map with a map of
our house where I had kind of put an X
over all the parts that really needed to
be vacuumed and it was it was great she
even asked me to sleep on the couch at
night because I guess she wanted to
vacuum all night in our room and so I
was just it was it was great all around
not too I mean I nailed the gift not to
Pat myself on the back or anything but I
just wanted to tell you that all right
this is exciting some feminists got a
maybe you heard about this they got a
sex strike going over the weekend the
strike started with Alyssa Milano who's
been in convulsions of rage for days now
over the Georgia abortion law and
finally on Friday she decided to take
things up a notch and she said we're
gonna do a sex strike this is what she
said our reproductive rights are being
erased until women have legal control
over our own bodies we just cannot risk
pregnancy join me by not having sex
until hey so it's just kind of a funny
phrase join me by not having sex anyway
join me by not having sex until we get
bodily autonomy back I'm calling for a
hashtag sex strike pass it on now a
number of feminists came out in support
of the sex strike and they got it
trending on social media reading a
couple of supportive comments just to
give you an idea
Maureen Shaw said our feminists for
mothers fought for sexual liberation
which goes hand-in-hand with bodily
autonomy it's up to us to protect it
desperate times
for desperate measures sex strike it
sounds like a movie or something
desperate times call for desperate
measures
sex strike columnist Sarah Reese Jones
says hey everyone upset about Melissa
Lana Milano's sex strike
thanks for helping this trend that was
the point because women's lives are in
danger
PS it's not Alyssa Milano's fault that
our culture is patriarchal she doesn't
own that just because she's
acknowledging it someone else says sorry
boys yes I said boys men should know
better than to make decisions on
something they know nothing about our
bodies our choices hash tag sex tribe
and then there were some men who were
supporting there expressing their
support of the sex strike as well one
guy said men have autonomy over their
own bodies women deserve equal
reproductive rights free from government
interference I joined my friends Alyssa
Milano in supporting a sex strike until
women have equal protection under the
law all right um there's there's a lot
to be said here about this but I want to
focus just for a moment at the beginning
here on these pitiful men I mean imagine
being a weak emasculated submissive man
who supports the murder of children
because you're afraid that feminists
might yell at you if you don't support
it and you've given up your soul and
your man card and your masculinity and
your credibility and your respect and
everything in order to obey your
feminist overlords and you hope that at
least it will help you you know with the
ladies you're thinking because you're
because you're cowering to them but
actually it doesn't it has the opposite
effect because all of the truly
beautiful and worthwhile women want
nothing to do with a submissive milksop
who tolerates the killing of children
and so that's already backfired on you
and now you find that even the women who
will potentially be with you have now
boycotted sex so that you hugh and your
fellow whidbey men are the only ones
being punished it's it's you've given up
everything and now they're boycotting
you
because you're the oh that's the thing
or of course conservative men want
nothing to do with feminists so
conservative men are not affected by
this it's only going to be men like this
guy that tweeted this they're the only
guys who are going to be affected and so
then what do you do you go online and
pretend to support the measure so yes I
support this sex strike too I am sure
these guys are so pathetic I almost feel
sorry for them almost but then I
remember that they are apologists for
the mass killing of children and so I
don't feel so bad anymore
I get very close to feeling bad for them
and then I remember who these guys are
and all of a sudden that sympathy goes
away so there's there's that but another
thought I'm having is that last week we
we should really stop and appreciate
this that last week was a banner week
for pro lifers it could not have gotten
any better well they could have gotten
better if they overturned Rovi way
that's really the only thing that could
have made it better because think about
what happened last week the Georgia law
was passed banning abortion after six
weeks we have that hugely successful
pro-life rally and then feminists decide
to stop having sex at the end of the
week feminists become celibate I mean
you couldn't have asked for a better way
to you couldn't ask for a better
capstone on the week than that it really
is incredible we that was I almost got
tired of winning last week almost but of
course the biggest takeaway is that
Alyssa Milano and her friends what
they're doing here is they are
acknowledging the effectiveness of
abstinence
so she says we can't risk pregnancy so
let's stop having sex
yes exactly Alyssa that's that's that's
the point that's what we've been saying
if you aren't sure that you want a baby
then it's foolish to risk pregnancy
which means it's foolish to have sex so
a sex strike is a great idea I I fully
support it
I I don't that's why conservatives and
pro-lifers we're totally on board with
this I think it's a great idea in fact I
would say go further than that
keep keep the sex strike going
indefinitely or at least until you get
married and if you never get married
then yeah you should really own the
Khans you should really you know show us
what's what by being celibate your whole
life right I would again I cannot
express this enough
I am fully supportive of any feminist
who wants to be celibate I I think it's
awesome I could not be a bigger fan of
that idea
especially if you're not married how
else do they think we're gonna react
like what do they think is gonna happen
these feminists who say they're gonna
they're pledging celibate celibacy what
do they think we're gonna they think all
the Conservatives go no feminists no no
please have sex we want you to know
please anything but that no we're not
gonna react that way because as I said
first of all it doesn't punish us
conservative men generally will avoid
left-wing feminists like the plague but
more importantly you're doing exactly
what we've been advocating all along and
you're doing it for the reasons that
we've been giving giving also you're
avoiding sex because you don't want to
risk pregnancy when you're not in a
position to care for a baby the only
difference is that you think that
killing the baby is a viable option and
the only reason you're going on a sext
right now is because you're afraid that
you'll be prevented from doing that
which is which is pretty horrible and
morally deranged but the the basic idea
here we agree with which is sex is
something that naturally fundamentally
it creates babies and anytime you have
sex there's a chance of a baby being
created so if you don't
on a baby then don't have sex that's
yeah we're on board and we've been
saying that for years it's great that
feminists have finally caught on and our
understanding that so I think it's
wonderful and of course a little the
last thing that comes to mind when you
think about this is how we're always
told that the sex lives of feminists and
liberals and everyone you their sex
lives are none of our business and
that's true I agree it's not a it's none
of my business I don't want to hear
about it yet they're constantly
advertising what they're doing in the
bedroom or what they're not doing in
this case but if you're gonna put it out
there and tell us I say thumbs up great
idea keep it going all right um
I am sad to report that representative
Rasheeda Talib has been victimized again
really sad tell you this poor woman she
she apparently has been she's being
unfairly attacked again she sent out
this statement on Twitter today she said
policing my words twisting and turning
them to ignite vile attacks on me will
not work all of you are trying to
silence me will fail miserably I will
never allow you to take my words out of
context to push your racist and hateful
agenda the truth will always win that's
the that's the statement she put up so
why are these quote vile attacks being
waged this time well because of this she
was on a podcast called skullduggery
which is a Yahoo News podcast apparently
and in the course of that discussion
this is what she said I'm gonna read I'm
gonna read verbatim and I'm gonna read
the entire context
she says it's out of context well here
is the entire context of what she said
she said there's always kind of a
calming feeling I tell folks when I
think of the Holocaust and the tragedy
of the Holocaust and the fact that it
was my ancestors Palestinians who lost
and in some lost their lives their
livelihood their human dignity their
existence in many ways have been wiped
out and some people's passports and just
all of it was in the name of trying to
create a safe haven for Jews post the
holocaust post the tragedy and the
horrific persecution of Jews across the
world at that time and I loved the fact
that was my ancestors that provided that
right in many ways but they did it in a
way that took their human dignity away
and it was forced on them okay so
putting aside the it's a little bit
unintelligible a little bit incoherent
but putting that aside a calming feeling
when I think of the Holocaust what now
here's the thing I don't need to twist
those words to make them seem bizarre at
best because they just are bizarre if
you're gonna start a sentence with I get
a calming feeling when I think of if
this is like Mad Libs or something and
in the sentence I get a calming feeling
when I think of now there are a lot of
things you could fill in the blank with
you could say sunsets beaches puppies
rainbows I got a calming feeling when I
think of rainbows any of those would
work fine perfectly fine but Holocaust
you get a calming feeling when you think
of the Holocaust now look the rest of
the context she does talk about at the
Holocaust was a tragedy and a terrible
thing so she says that fine and I guess
that's what she's referring to which is
that while you're taking my words out of
context I called it a tragedy great yeah
you did but you also did say that you
get a calming feeling when you think of
the Holocaust you did say that it's
right there verbatim that's what you
said and there's there there's really
nothing you can say before or after that
sentence that's gonna make that sentence
okay so the context can't always save
you there are certain sentences that if
you say them
you've said them and there's in it's
there's nothing that you can say after
that to make it okay unless the context
is you're quoting someone so I just used
the phrase I get a calming feeling when
I think of Holocaust but the context for
me is I'm quoting her so that's okay
that context makes it okay for me to say
but if you're expressing your own
feelings there's it it nothing's gonna
make that not completely insane sorry
but today isn't the only Democrat woman
being victimized by verbatim quotes this
seems to happen a lot with with Democrat
women Alexandria Kaiser Cortez has once
again fallen victim to this form of
abuse apparently as she wrote this over
the weekend she said this is a technique
of the GOP to take dry humor and sarcasm
literally and quote fact-checking like
the world ending in twelve years you'd
have to have the social intelligence of
a sea sponge to think it's literal but
the GOP is basically Dwight from the
office so who knows oh she's so
relatable isn't she she's a relatable
millennial making office jokes but I
want to vote for her based on that she
relates she gets me but dry humor and
sark so she's now saying that when she
said the world's gonna end in twelve
years that was sarcasm
so why what so the world isn't ending
then she's saying she was being
sarcastic about it so this whole time
was she making fun of environmentalists
I'll be honest when I read the green New
Deal I might like many people my first
reaction was this has to be a parody
this has to be satire there's no way
this is real and now she's telling us
what that it was this is all some this
is performance art on her part this has
all been an act by her is that what
she's telling us because if that's the
case then Bravo it's brilliant
but I feel like that's not like that
can't possibly be it you know the
this is the tactic used by people like
Alexandra Kaiser Cortinas and a lot of
these new female Congress women on the
Democratic side where they go out saying
stupid insane things and then all we do
is quote what they said and criticize it
which is perfectly valid and there and
they've been victimized that's the way
it always goes alright I can't let this
one go without mentioning it here's an
argument that has gone viral because I
guess people think it's very persuasive
and so I've got to say something about
Heather Anne Campbell is a TV writer
apparently and she wrote this recently
and I've seen it all over the place
she said sperm has DNA DNA is when life
begins every sperm is a potential human
being so no more self pleasuring
gentlemen unless you want to be
convicted of a felony carrying a cell
phone in your pocket damages your sperm
so no cell phones either skirts only for
men to protect sperm and she goes on
talking about other ways the other forms
of legislation that will need to be
passed in order to stop men from killing
their sperm and you get the point here
the the analogy the comparison she's
trying to draw she's clearly trying to
equate that with outlawing abortion and
saying it's it's a similar kind of thing
now even though this is a ridiculously
stupid argument you do hear versions of
it a lot I suppose I did last week the
whatever it was the seven dumbest
pro-abortion arguments I guess I should
have included this because what we're
doing here is a conflating sperm with an
actual human being
conflating them on the basis that they
both have DNA and she's saying DNA is
when life begins no one is saying that
DNA is when life begins I've never heard
that sentence before it doesn't make any
sense
people pro lifers say that conception is
when life begins
but nobody is saying that everything
that has DNA is its own life and should
be treated like a person your
fingernails have DNA okay your skin
cells have DNA nobody thinks that you're
committing genocide when you scratch
your nose or when you clip your your
nails why because the issue is that the
DNA and question in that case when you
clip to your fingernails or when you
scratch your nose that DNA is your DNA
but even if you if all the if you shed
skin cells you still continue existing
as a person you go on surviving even as
your DNA is shed through your skin's own
but the being that forms upon conception
becomes a thing with unique DNA that's
the point here it's not just your DNA
okay your child does not just have your
DNA this is a unique separate entity
with its own DNA that's the point
so sperm is an ingredient for lack of a
better term it's an ingredient that
helps to make this separate person but
it it is it is not itself a separate
person I think it's a really crucial
distinction here in us now this is kind
of a crude analogy but I understand that
it doesn't work a hundred percent but no
analogy does so it's similar to if
you're gonna say well sperm is a is a
potential person that's like looking at
a stick of butter or a cup of sugar or a
bag of flour and saying it's a potential
cake no the cake is when all those
ingredients are combined and mixed okay
now you have a cake and if you go and
you you put it in the oven nobody you
know no one says that it's only a cake
once it's been in there for 30 minutes
or I don't know I don't bake how long
does it cake go in the oven now when
we put a cake in the oven we say a cake
is in the oven
you know if you made a cake and you put
it in the oven and it's been in there
for one minute
and I come in and I say hey what's in
the oven you're gonna say a cake a cakes
in the oven
you're not gonna say oh a glob of
ingredients a mixture of ingredients are
in the oven now you're gonna say that's
a cake okay not it not just a potential
cake but a cake and if the cake isn't
isn't cooked all the way if it's
undercooked and someone serves you an
undercooked cake what are you gonna say
you can say this cake is undercooked
you're not gonna say oh this cake is
still ingredients it's not a cake yet
so that's the difference okay sperm is
one of the ingredients that goes into
making a person it's not itself a person
so if sperm is destroyed nobody thinks
that a person has been destroyed just
like if if I go and I steal your stick
of butter
you're never you're not gonna say oh you
stole my cake it's not a cake yet but if
you had it already and you had it all
mixed and it was just in the oven for a
second and I come in and I take it and I
throw it out you're gonna say you
destroyed my cake
you see that's that's the difference
you're if I feel like the distinction is
relatively easy to understand and
they're just pretending they don't
understand it all right let's go to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from Amanda says Matt
love your show wanted to ask you about a
conversation I had with an atheist
friend recently he insisted confidently
that the Bible is full of contradictions
he said if it contradicts itself even
once then that proves it's not the Word
of God he listed a bunch that I can't
even remember but it was a long list
later I looked it up and found an
apologist who said basically that the
claim the Bible contradicts itself is
ridiculous and a lie by atheists his
explanation seemed logical but are
atheists really making this up my friend
did have many examples was he lying or
what
thanks for
taking the time to read and again I
appreciate your show all right um this
is a good question this is I like
questions like this very meaty gives us
a lot to talk about
alright so we got a few things going on
here right we've got the claim that the
Bible contradicts itself then the claim
that this proves that it's not the Word
of God and then the competing claim that
such claims are ridiculous
and unfounded I happen to basically
disagree with everyone you've cited
there
I don't believe ultimately that the
Bible contradicts itself but the idea
that those claims are completely
ridiculous is itself ridiculous and I
think an apologist I don't know what
apologists you're referring to there but
an apologist who just waves off this
issue of Bible contradictions it's adds
but ridiculous I don't even have to talk
about that I think that's someone who is
way overcompensating and being far too
defensive now yes the job of an
apologist is to defend the Bible so
defend the faith what a pilot being an
apologist is so in that sense they're
going to be defensive but I mean I mean
defensive in the negative sense of of
you know defensive in the sense of
really not defending of not even
engaging with the argument but instead
completely dismissing it so just because
a statement is wrong now to say the
Bible contradicts itself I think that
that statement is wrong but just because
it's wrong doesn't mean it's ridiculous
necessarily and if we treat every
challenge to our faith as ridiculous
then we only show that we are
empty-headed spin-doctors and there's no
reason to take us seriously if we're not
going to take the challenges to our
faith seriously then the people who are
challenging our faith have no reason to
take us seriously and so we don't want
to we don't want to do that we want to
be intelligent thoughtful and honest so
Bible contradictions now all I'm going
to focus on the Gospels when talking
about this and this is an issue
I've thought a lot about this I've read
a lot so I wanted specifically when it
comes to the Gospels because we got to
focus
this can't be a five-hour conversation
we got to focus somewhere you'll hear
about contradictions in the Old
Testament too especially in the first
book Genesis where scholars these days
some scholars propose what's called the
documentary hypothesis which says that
Pentateuch was cobbled together from
like four different sources which they
claim in some cases compete with one
another and they'll cite for instance
the two different creation accounts
seemingly the the seeming different
versions of the Noah story that can be
found in there and so on I'm not gonna
focus on that but I will say that I
reject this idea of that you know these
books were cobbled together in this way
it doesn't even really now it doesn't
doesn't make sense because if if someone
was going to cobble together these
different sources
why wouldn't they iron out the
differences why would they just put all
these competing versions in together and
then send them out there so I don't
believe that I don't know if I
necessarily believe that Moses wrote
those books because they do narrate his
own death after all so which would seem
to create a problem there but I don't
believe the idea that you know they were
cobbled together from various different
authors so there are ways of harmonizing
those apparent contradictions in Genesis
and in the other four books it's not
that hard to do but I would rather focus
on on the Gospels with the Gospels we've
got four of them as you know and they do
appear at multiple points to contradict
each other each other I I do think the
the differences can be explained some
easier than others but to say that's
ridiculous to point to those
contradictions is just not honest there
is stuff in the Gospels that an
objective and honest person could point
to and say well yeah that seems to be a
contradiction and I think the correct
response from us is to say yeah I see
you say that but here are some thoughts
about how these things might be might
fit together there are some easy ones so
all of the Gospels have Jesus saying
different things on the cross and it's
not hard to imagine that he said all of
those things and each gospel just has a
somewhat condensed version of it so we
have we have the the seven last words of
Christ but no gospel individually has
all seven they all have different things
but that's not to me that's that's not a
difficult one he said all of them the
Gospels focus on different things have
him you know they they record different
things that he said and you put it all
together and you have you have the seven
last words makes sense to me
easy enough also from the cross one
gospel has both thieves mocking Jesus
while another Luke has one of the one of
the thieves sticking up for Jesus we
know the famous story of the penitent
thief which is my one of my favorite
stories and the Gospel as I've shared
before so how do you harmonize that well
maybe the one thief had a change of
heart while on the cross I think it
actually makes the story even more
powerful in some ways that even
initially on the cross he was defiant
and then had a change of heart really
really at the last moment so it's a
perfectly plausible explanation there
earlier in the story Matthew has the
lengthy Sermon on the Mount that we all
know of when we think of the Sermon on
the Mount we're thinking of Matthew's
version of it while the other Gospels
give us just the Beatitudes and then
they have the other teachings from the
Sermon interspersed throughout the
narrative
whereas Matthew has it all in one chunk
there on the Sermon on the Mount well it
stands to reason that Jesus gave the
same teaching multiple times Jesus was a
traveling preacher he went around giving
these teachings and it makes a lot of
sense that he would have given them more
than once to different audiences because
it's not like everybody in the region
was there for the Sermon on the Mount so
I don't think there's a problem there
there's a lot of stuff like that
the
order of things being jostled around
which i think is no big deal
John has the cleansing of the temple at
the beginning of his narrative whereas
the Synoptics Matthew Mark and Luke have
it at the end it's possible that Jesus
did it twice but that seems probably
unlikely it's unlikely that a person
could get away with doing that twice
especially because in a Synoptics Jesus
cleansing the temple is one of the
things that leads to his to his
execution so it seems that John moved
the order of things around a little bit
he also has Jesus being crucified on a
different day now this is only a
contradiction if you fail to understand
what John is trying to do with the
Gospels and that's one of the main it's
one of the important things here when
you're reading the Bible we have to
realize that the Bible is it's it's not
it's not like one person wrote the
entire Bible there are different books
different forms of writing and they're
all trying to do different things and so
we have to know what the writer was
trying to do what was what was his point
what was his method what was his style
right so John is clearly a more poetic
more theologically focused document than
are the Synoptics I think the Synoptics
are clearly more just straight
historical you know accounts whereas
John is doing something more theological
and once you understand that once you
understand that John is not writing a
simple biography like the others though
it is biographical of course then the
switching up of the order and the other
changes that John makes aren't a big
deal John is also very different
stylistically you'll notice when you
read John that all of the people who are
you know given dialogue in in John's
account they all sound different like
Jesus sounds different in John's account
than he does in the Synoptics but that
again is stylistic so I think the call
that a contradiction is to show that you
don't understand what these writers are
trying to do and what John is trying to
do
so I think all of that you know is is
basically easy to explain and that's
what I would say to your atheist friend
there are for me though if I were to
think about what our contradictions in
the gospel that are more challenging to
understand and explain I think there are
two there are two areas I would point to
and they bookend the Gospels so there's
the the end and the beginning and the
the part at the end would be how many
angels were at the tomb when the when
the women arrived on Easter morning just
going from memory here so we have mark
mark says that there was a says there
was a young man who created the women
matthew has an angel Luke has I believe
two men and then John has two angels so
that's something atheists are going to
point to and say there's a contradiction
you know Mark has a young man and then
John at you know John being the last
gospel written says it was two angels
well which was it was a young man or two
angels so there's two things that to
keep in mind there first of all in the
Bible
angels are referred to us goes back to
the old tech goes back to Genesis you
find angels being referred to as men
especially young men quite frequently so
that seems like a contradiction until
you look at it in the context of in the
in the full biblical context and you
understand that it was common for
biblical writers to call to refer to
angels as men so there's that what about
the number though we've got one or two
and apologists will generally address
that by saying well listen just because
you say there was one angel or one
person or whatever that doesn't mean
there weren't two so it's like you know
the comparison I've heard is if you say
you know a police officer pulled you
over on your way home from work and you
told somebody the police officer pulled
me over well what if there were actually
two police officers in the car and you
only said eight police up does that mean
that you're lying or you're
contradicting the truth no it just means
that you're saying it's true there was a
police officer pulled you over there was
also a second one who you didn't mention
because he didn't think it was necessary
but that doesn't mean that what you said
is untrue so that's generally how that's
dealt with I don't find that to be a
totally satisfying explanation but it's
it's you know it's it works anyway and
then at the other end I think the most
difficult seeming contradiction is in
the infancy narrative where you've got
you know only two Gospels give you the
infancy narrative and that's fine the
other two don't mention it that's not a
contradiction they just don't mention it
Matthew and Luke give us an infancy
narrative and Matthew has Luke has the
you know the famous story of the Holy
Family going from Nazareth to Bethlehem
for the census and then they're there
and the Shepherd's come and there's the
presentation in the temple and then they
go back to Nazareth and that's that's
sort of the story and then in Matthew's
Gospel they're already in Bethlehem to
begin the story and Mary gives birth and
then the Three Magi come and then they
have to flee because Herod sends the you
know Joseph is warned in a dream that
that people are coming to kill their
child so they flee to Egypt and and then
after after a length of time then they
go to Nazareth so the contradiction
there is that Luke does not mention the
flight to Egypt and Matthew does so
again the way of dealing with that is
saying that yes Luke doesn't mention it
he also doesn't he doesn't say that it
didn't happen he just doesn't mention it
and that's basically the way to deal
with it again I find that it's it's that
war that explanation works it does work
it's true that Matthew does not say it
didn't happen it does seem like a rather
significant detail to omit from your
account and so we're left kind of
because in in in Luke's account he's got
presentation at temple and then next
sentence they're going back to Nazareth
so what we have to do to fit Matthew
into Luke is to stick this entire story
of the flight to Egypt in between those
two sentences which is which seems like
quite a detail to fit in between two
sentences but I think that's basically
you know again it's not technically a
contradiction and and I'm also k saying
look you know I can explain most of this
pretty easily I think any reasonable
person can there are a couple parts in
there that I don't fully understand and
I'm okay saying I don't know you know I
I don't fully get it I'm not totally
sure how these things fit together I
have faith that they do and I think it's
okay to say that I think it's okay to
admit that I don't think we have to
claim that we understand everything 100%
in fact I think we should realize that
we don't had admitted and be okay with
that
and then continue studying and try to
increase our understanding so that is my
very long and uh explanation for that
and that's how I would maybe think of a
more succinct way of giving that tear to
your atheist friends because they'll
probably fall asleep if you give an
explanation like I just did just as
everyone in the audience is probably
falling asleep by now so we will leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed Alyssa
Milano calls for pro-abortion women to
go on a sex strike thereby reducing the
number of unwanted pregnancies and
thereby reducing abortion good job I
guess for the left life is a sexually
transmitted disease from which no one
has ever recovered for the right life is
a precious gift we'll analyze the
difference at the Michael Noel's show